all our thoughts are with Detective
Chief Inspector John Caldwell and his
family after last week's abhorrent
shooting in Oma
a man of extraordinary courage his first
thought was to protect the children he
had been coaching
president vondoline and I Stand United
with the people and leaders of all
communities across Northern Ireland
those trying to drag us back into the
past will never succeed
this afternoon
I welcomed president vondeline to
Windsor to continue our discussions
about the Northern Ireland protocol
I'm pleased to report
that we have now made a decisive
breakthrough
together
we have changed the original protocol
and are today announcing the New Windsor
framework
today's agreement
delivers smooth flowing trade within the
whole United Kingdom protects the
northern Ireland's place in our Union
and Safeguard sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland
now these negotiations have not always
been easy
but I'd like to pay an enormous personal
tribute to Ursula for her vision in
recognizing the possibility of a new way
forward
and to my colleagues the foreign and
Northern Ireland secretaries for their
steadfast leadership
the United Kingdom and European Union
may have had our differences in the past
but we are allies
trading partners and Friends
something that we've seen clearly in the
past year as we joined with others to
support Ukraine
this is the beginning of a new chapter
in our relationship
for a quarter of a century the Belfast
Good Friday agreement has endured
because at its heart
is respect for the aspirations and
identity of all communities
today's agreement is about preserving
that delicate balance and charting a new
way forward for the people of Northern
Ireland
I am standing here today
because I believe we have found ways to
end the uncertainty and challenge for
the people of Northern Ireland
we have taken three big steps forward
first today's agreement delivers the
smooth flow of trade within the United
Kingdom Goods destined for Northern
Ireland will travel through a new Green
Lane with a separate red lane
for Goods at risk of moving onto the EU
in the Green Lane burdensome Customs
bureaucracy will be scrapped it means
food retailers like supermarkets
restaurants and wholesalers will no
longer need hundreds of certificates for
every lorry
and we will end the situation where food
made to UK rules could not be sent to
and sold in Northern Ireland
this means that if food is available on
Supermarket shelves in Great Britain
then it will be available on Supermarket
shelves in Northern Ireland
and unlike the protocol today's
agreement means people sending Parcels
to friends or family or doing their
shopping online
will have to complete no Customs
paperwork
this means we have removed any sense of
a border in the Irish sea
second we have protected Northern
Ireland's place in the Union
we've amended the legal text of the
protocol to ensure we can make critical
vat and excise changes for the whole of
the UK
for example on alcohol Duty meaning our
reforms to cut the cost of a pint in the
pub will now apply in Northern Ireland
the same quintessentially British
products like trees plants and seed
potatoes will again be available in
Northern Ireland's garden centers
onerous travels on pet requirements have
been removed
and today's agreement also delivers a
landmark settlement on medicines
from now on drugs approved for use by
the UK's medicines regulator will be
automatically available in every
Pharmacy and Hospital in Northern
Ireland
third
today's agreement safeguards sovereignty
for the people of Northern Ireland
the only EU law that applies in Northern
Ireland under the framework
is the minimum necessary to avoid a hard
border with Ireland and allow Northern
Irish businesses to continue accessing
the EU Market
but I know that many people in Northern
Ireland are worried about being subject
to changes in EU Goods laws
to address that today's agreement
introduces a new Stormont break
many had called for Stormont to have a
say
over these laws but the storm won't
break goes further and means that
stormwalk can in fact stop them from
applying in Northern Ireland
this will establish a clear process
through which the democratically elected
assembly can pull an emergency break for
changes to EU Goods rules that would
have significant and lasting effects on
everyday lives
if the break is pulled the UK government
will have a veto
this gives the institutions of the Good
Friday agreement in Northern Ireland a
powerful new Safeguard based on
cross-community consent
I believe the Windsor framework marks a
turning point for the people of Northern
Ireland it fixes the Practical problems
they face
it preserves the balance of the Belfast
Good Friday agreement
now of course parties will want to
consider the agreement in detail a
process that will need time and care
today's agreement is written in the
language of laws and treaties
but really
it's about much more than that
it's about stability
in Northern Ireland
it's about real people
and real businesses
it's about showing that our Union that
has lasted for centuries can and will
endure
and it's about breaking down the
barriers between us
setting aside the arguments that for too
long have divided us
and remembering that fellow feeling that
defines us
this family
of Nations
this United Kingdom
thank you
good afternoon I think prime minister
it is an honor and a pleasure to be here
in winter with you
and it is with a great sense of
satisfaction that we stand here together
we are about to deliver on an important
commitment we made to each other a few
months ago
I remember our first discussions when we
saw eye to eye on how to support our
Ukrainian friends
and I was encouraged by our trustful and
strong cooperation on this crucial
geostrategic issue
but I also remember how the two of us
were honest with each other
about the difficulties in our bilateral
relationship
and it was vital to put that on the
right footing too
we committed to work hard together to do
so
we knew that for us to be able to make
the most of the potential of our
partnership
Solutions were needed for the issues
around the protocol on island Northern
Ireland
we knew it was not going to be easy
we knew we needed to listen to each
other's concerns very carefully
above all we had to listen to the
concerns of the people of Northern
Ireland
we knew we had to work hard with clear
minds and determination
but we also both knew their regime that
we could do it
because we were both generally committed
to find a practical solution
for people and for all communities in
Northern Ireland
today we can take pride in the fact that
we have delivered on that commitment
because today we have agreed we have
reached an agreement in principle
on the Windsor framework
The Windsor framework lays down new
Arrangements on island Northern Ireland
this new framework will allow us to
begin a new chapter
it provides for long-lasting solutions
that both of us are confident
will work for all people and businesses
in Northern Ireland
solutions that respond directly to the
concerns they have raised
prime minister we worked hard across a
wide range of areas
the new arrangements are delivering a
comprehensive package
so that we can address in a definitive
way the issues faced in everyday lives
I will only mention two examples that I
find most telling indeed the New Windsor
framework will ensure that the same food
will be available on Supermarket shelves
in Northern Ireland as in the rest of
the UK
and furthermore the New Windsor
framework will permanently enable all
medicines including novel ones
to be available in Northern Ireland at
the same time under the same conditions
across the UK
for this to work we have agreed on
strong safeguards
like it access labels and enforcement
procedures that will protect the
Integrity of the European Union's single
Market
the New Windsor framework respects and
protects our respective markets and our
respective legitimate interests
and most importantly it protects the
very hard earned peace gains of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
for the people of Northern Ireland and
across the island of Ireland
violence has no place in our society
I condemn wholeheartedly
the shooting of the psni officer in
Northern Ireland last week
and my thoughts are with the officer and
his family and friends
this year will Mark the 25th anniversary
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
an important milestone
of the historic peace process
the New Windsor framework is here to
benefit people in Northern Ireland
and support all communities celebrating
peace on the island of Ireland
and this is why I believe we can now
open a new chapter in our partnership a
stronger EU UK relationship
standing as close Partners shoulder to
shoulder now and in the future many
things
we have time some questions from the
media can I start with the BBC
thank you Chris Mason BBC News if the
Democratic unionist party don't go back
into government in Northern Ireland
after all of this does It ultimately
amount to a failure question to both of
you
well Chris I think today marks a turning
point for Northern Ireland I've spent a
lot of time listening to communities
their business is there the unionist
community as well
understanding their concerns and I
believe that today's framework addresses
them
it ensures that we can move Goods freely
around our UK internal Market it
protects Northern Ireland's place in the
union and it's safe to guard sovereignty
for Northern Ireland's people
but I also recognize that parties and
communities across Northern Ireland will
want to take the time to consider the
detail of what we're announcing today
and we should give them the time and the
space to do that and I fully respect
that
but I believe that what we have achieved
today is a real breakthrough and it's
now for the parties to consider that and
decide themselves how to take it forward
and build a better future for people in
Northern Ireland
I think it's
just read today and what we have
achieved
and indeed a lot will happen
the establishmenting of the Green Lane
for example and the red lane for goods
there are using of an amount of
paperwork
reduce customs and checks on the ground
sharing Customs data information in real
time all these will drastically
facilitate when implemented it's a big
step forward and I think what is
exceptional is that we managed to find
an agreement for solutions that will
protect our respective single markets
and this is a lot and therefore I really
want to thank for the excellent
cooperation and I really want to thank
our teams also for um all the time
they've invested all the knowledge
um the result is extraordinary
no I'd Echo what Ursula said about
thanking our teams and actually Chris to
just building on what Ursula said I
often we focus on the politics of
situations Westminster and all the rest
of it but this is about the people of
Northern Ireland about the communities
about the businesses there and what's
best for them and I believe that the
Windsor framework that we've agreed
today really resolves the challenges
that have been raised it resolved all
the Practical issues on the ground it
puts people in charge of their Destiny
and that's why I represents such a major
breakthrough and I hope everyone can
recognize that and take the time to
consider it but this is this framework
will start making a positive difference
to people's lives in Northern Ireland
almost immediately and regardless of all
the politics of this I think that is
something that hopefully all of us can
recognize and celebrate uh can we turn
next to RTE
to Reign for RCA here the unionists say
they want to be treated the same and
it's it's to both leader they want to be
treated the same as any other part of
the UK however Northern Ireland is the
only part of the UK that chair is a land
border with the EU so there will have to
be some differences for Northern Ireland
compared to the rest of the UK
do you believe the unionists will accept
different treatment and can you point to
how for instance the European court of
justice will have jurisdiction in
Northern Ireland
what if you want to take that first I
said I'll I'll
just actually just Echo what I I just
said John actually about
yes of course politics matters and
parties in Northern Ireland unionist
communities will want to take the time
to consider what we've announced today
digest the detail and we should give
them the time and the space to do that
but if you focus on people on families
on communities on businesses I think
people will see that the framework we've
agreed today delivers significant
improvements in almost every aspect of
their lives that have seen disruption
and Challenge from the protocol and that
is something that I think can be
celebrated and recognized and that
benefit will start coming very quickly
now there are a range of things that I
heard when I talk to communities in
Northern Ireland and because of the
breadth and the comprehensive nature of
this framework and you heard some of it
in my remarks earlier I think we're
addressing all those practical
challenges and indeed safeguarding
sovereignty as well and I know that's
something that's particularly important
to communities in Northern Ireland you
know with regard to the role of EU law
they're recognize that with the consent
of people in Northern Ireland Northern
Ireland has access to the single market
and I think we all collectively share an
ambition to avoid as you say a hard
border between Northern Ireland and the
Republic and that's why there's a role
for EU law in Northern Ireland but that
happens with consent and as a result of
the agreements that we've reached today
there is further Democratic
accountability of that role of EU law
with the new storm won't break which
provides a very powerful mechanism
for the storm one institution to use
when it has concerns and I think that is
really important part of correcting the
Democratic deficit that existed and
providing reassurance to everyone in
Northern Ireland that they are in
control of their own destiny
yes indeed the European court of justice
is the soul and ultimate Arbiter of EU
law that's natural because it's
prescribed by the EU legal order
so the ecj will have the final say on EU
law and single Market issues
um but we have in this Windsor framework
worked hard on the rules that existed
before not only the ecj on EU law but
also the arbitration panel are not EU
laws and this includes the new storm and
break
which is based on the petition of
concern that comes from the Good Friday
agreement
so we have built on this peace process
the next step we've kind of leveled up
or improved the overall mechanism I
think important is in our Windsor
framework that we are putting also in
Place several mechanisms that should
avoid having to resort to the storm and
break which is an emergency mechanism so
intense extensive consultations with the
UK and Northern Ireland stakeholders on
new EU laws but also consultations of
the EU by the UK on UK planned
regulatory changes this is important for
us and with view on Ireland
of course there is has always been the
full commitment and there is the full
commitment of the European Union to
safeguard the Belfast Good Friday
agreement in all its Dimensions no hard
border on the island of Ireland and of
course that we fully protect the
Integrity of the EU single Market
uh can I turn next to the express
there's some list of Daily Express I
um as a test of your leadership are you
planning to have a vote on this deal and
if so how tough are you prepared to be
on Boris Johnson and members of the ERG
if they decide to oppose it and I wonder
if I could just ask president bondoline
a question
um can you explain to us why vicious
unak's been able to negotiate these
concessions when his three predecessors
were unable to thank you
so yes Parliament will have a vote of
the appropriate time and that vote will
be respected but as I said earlier I
think it's important that we give
everyone the time and the space they
need to consider the detail of the
framework that we've announced today
because it is comprehensive in nature
and that will take time for people to
digest But ultimately this isn't
necessarily about me it's not about
politicians it's about the people in
Northern Ireland
it's about what's best for them it's
about those families those businesses
and what this framework what this
agreement will do to improve their lives
and I believe that the changes that we
have made the breakthroughs that we have
been able to put forward together will
make an enormous difference
we can now say that Goods will throw
freely smoothly across the UK internal
Market that we've protected Northern
Ireland's place in our Union that we've
safeguarded sovereignty for Northern
Ireland's people those are all
significant achievements and that's what
we should focus on and I think all of us
know about the stability that is
required in Northern Ireland the
delicate balance of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement and how important that
is today's framework means that that
balance is restored and that's why I
think this is a very significant step
forward it marks a turning point for the
people of Northern Ireland today and I
very much hope as a result of this they
can look forward to a better future
I think it is very important to take
note of the fact that the two of us when
we met for the very first time we agreed
um that I mean if you look at the huge
challenges we are facing together
whether it is the atrocious Russian war
in Ukraine or the fight against climate
change
we have so much in common we're fighting
for the same values we're standing on
the same side shoulder by shoulder
and we want the best solution
for the people of Northern Ireland in
the situation that we have right now so
there was a very constructive
attitude from the very beginning to
solve problems to find Solutions
practical solutions for everyday life of
the people and businesses in Northern
Ireland that's what we've done and we've
jointly developed the solutions
it needed a lot of Goodwill and
knowledge and we have jointly agreed on
that now so I'm very happy about the
agreement that we found with Windsor
framework
and lastly have we got lesoir
could be good enough for the Belgium
newspaper would you say that the trust
is back between the UK and the EU and
would you say that this deal will help
the UK to participate again to Horizon
the research program
do you want to start with us yes this
Windsor framework is good news for
scientists and researchers
in the European Union and in the UK
because of course the moment we have
finished this agreement so it's an
agreement in principle at the moment
it's implemented I am happy to start
immediately right now the work on an
association agreement which is the
precondition to join Horizon Europe so
good news for all those who are working
in research and science
I think I'd also just add to that
there's a there's a range of different
areas that we can cooperate productively
on and the president and I started that
work when we first met but if you look
at how we've responded to the situation
in Ukraine that's required very close
coordination on things like sanctions
policy which the president has LED and
we work very closely together on that
also energy security more broadly given
the interconnected nature of our energy
markets climate change is another area
and indeed illegal migration these are
all the types of things that we can
continue to make good progress on
working together to the benefit of all
of our communities that we represent and
I look forward to doing that with the
president wonder line as well
good
thank you very much for your time
foreign